penguins are they how they distract you
yeah you still believe the Penguins yeah
penguins is not real there's no actual
Bird that's a penguin yeah a bird with
wings that can't fly yeah right yeah
yeah right what do you think he's stupid
yeah we're not buying this penguin what
we are buying is the what is the weapon
that they say that they have there
microwave weapons microwave weapons
microwave weapons yeah
directed energy weapons
no this is real oh yeah there's a guy
going on podcasts hey what's she saying
he's saying that they have directed
energy weapons well they can cause
earthquakes around the world
who cares you don't want to know what's
going on here's something to think about
everyone's like whoa [__] UFOs are
real why do we only